who is the most popular actor in the
world ladies and gentlemen is a pretty
difficult question answer it sounds very
hard as a matter of fact but it's not
he's the comedian for Mexico his name
tonton floss no first name just tonkin
floss plane he just finished making his
first American picture around the world
in 80 days which incidentally was a very
very expensive picture to make my card
had to rent the world from Howard Jews
here he is ladies and gentlemen
conscience loss on film from Mexico to
present the awards for cinematography Oh
excuse me if I will keep one eye on you
and one eye on the board I am NOT crazy
the board will keep two eyes on me he is
not crazy
the only man is crazy here believe me is
the cameraman his completamente look
really believe me he will face anything
he will face the board he will face a
fire even face an actress he shall win a
prize every day but tonight in Hollywood
there are two big prices the prices for
Best Cinematography are won by the
winner is Rose Tattoo Jane 1/2
no bad sighs faithful the genie I'm very
grateful this evening I want to thank my
crew of the Hal Wallis and Paramount
Pictures and the Motion Picture Academy
arts and science make this possible
thank you
mr. Miller if you please I should like
to introduce the winner for color
cinematography in New York to catch a
thief
Robert Burt
thank you very much and thank you - hits